this is a production of cornell
university
perfect um yeah so it's it's it's really
remarkable what you guys have done i
almost feel like
everybody's here in fact when i walked
out of my office i expected to see other
people there
um who i've been you know following on
zoom and everything so and through the
slack channel so thank you guys for
doing this
and for um and persisting within um
what is really a novel environment that
we're all working to adapt
to um to and as we sit and talk about
plant adaptation and evolution
and breeding techniques to be able to do
that so we're just being as diverse and
as adaptable as the plants that we study
so maybe we're learning something from
them
and i just have to get a give a shout
out to paul's um
image that he has when he disappeared
that's really cool i didn't notice that
before so
very nice um i'll have to get more
creative with that
so i wanted to sort of uh boy when
when it transitioned into being a
virtual symposium
i decided i was going to try to sort of
blow things up a little bit so this is
my first time sort of presenting in this
way
i want to talk to you about really
holistically about what my lab is
working on
and how together as a group we
come together to think more diversely
about
plant form and function and that by
having a bunch of different systems that
we're working on
we're learning from each other and in
turn our research is benefiting from
um all of the you know crazy techniques
that we're using
and the diversity of ways that we're
viewing um
science and planet diversity and
and adaptation because of the different
systems that we're all working in
and and so that is one of the reasons
why i have a number of co-authors on
this talk and i will introduce them as i
go through
the slides but i just want to start by
saying i
work in phylogenetics is part of what i
do
and oftentimes people talk about the
tree of life and i always think of this
image because it's like oh there's a
tree of life and it's out there and if
we just
had it we could hold it in our hands and
understand everything that there is to
understand
um but more and more we're recognizing
that it's not so much a tree of life but
it's a web of life
and hold on one second i'm trying to
and um and rather than looking at each
of the leaves of this tree
one lineage at a time we're starting to
recognize how critical it is to
understand the interactions that are
happening among species and across
lineages
and how these influences of temporal and
spatial interactions can really alter
phenotypes in unpredictive ways so i
always say that your pheno your favorite
phenotype might actually be
the result not just of genetics but of
epigenetic interactions and organismal
interactions that influence it
um and so data about organismal
development and the genetic and
phenotypic diversity that it influences
are enabling us to look down the
branches of the tree of life and start
to understand the mechanisms by which
the leaves or the taxa that we're
interested in have evolved
and now it is not letting me go forward
why is that
all right let me try it this way you may
have to click the stream
yeah there's like 800 ways to do
everything and we're all learning them
as we
as we move into being advanced
technology experts each and every one of
us
um so then thinking about um the
a key goal in my lab is to characterize
and understand the realization of
phenotypic diversity through
developmental processes
so we're concerned with how development
patterns and processes
mediate evolutionary changes in
organismal form and function
and this includes the generation of
multiple phenotypes from one genotype or
even the convergence on a single
phenotype from multiple genotypic inputs
of course the environment is in there
too so that
makes things even more exciting so in
particular we're concerned with how
developmental patterns
can mediate evolutionary changes in
organismal form and function
um and one more way to represent this i
think about we
think about going from the genome to the
phenome and how have genomic and
developmental processes evolved
to generate new morphologies and does
the evolutionary history
of those organisms actually bias that
trajectory as it goes from genome to
phenome and
bias the evolution of novel morphologies
and so um in order to do this we need to
understand relationships we need to
resolve phylogenetic relationships
um at both species level as well as at
population levels
we can use then estimates of gene flow
or as fossil dating within phylogenetic
contexts to
understand timing of diversification and
then
we can characterize the genetic networks
that are associated with phenotypic
development
and investigate the role of those
networks not just in the individual but
also in evolving
morphologies across lineages
and so my uh this whatever outline slide
is
daunting and i promise you it it will
not be as daunting as it sounds but i'm
gonna go through these various
organisms and ideas
to kind of paint that picture of how we
can
use some of our findings to understand
better
how plants adapt and then how those
genes might be used not to
well to breed those into crop species
but also to understand how those
adaptations might evolve within the
population
or within the crop in which they're
being um being introduced
so i'm going to start today um by
talking about organ identity
and work that had been started by me
actually as a graduate student
thinking about the abc genes and organ
identity and this was of course in the
90s
1990s when um
the madsbox genes were coming to light
as really integral in understanding
floral development
and we looked to this abc model for the
construction rules for
how a flower develops and just going
quickly in arabidopsis you've got a
b and c class genes e-class genes seem
to be expressed everywhere
on a-class genes expressed in sepals and
petals and a
expression alone gave you sepals b and a
together gives you petals b and c
stamens and c carpels and one thing i
want to note here is that there's a
one-to-one correspondence
between organ identity and organ
morphology and arabidopsis and we'll see
we blow this out of the water in other
plants
but that means that a sepal looks like a
sepal and a petal looks like a petal a
stamen looks like a stamen and carpels
look like carpels
if you move into something like a
monocot that has two worlds of teaples
rather than separate steeples and petals
it had been proposed by a number of
researchers in the late 90s and early
2000s
that perhaps just the b-class genes have
moved over a bit
giving you two worlds of essentially
petals
right we can call them tables if you
want um but these are two identical
worlds
that have both a and b class genes and
this was proposed
um and so various researchers went out
to look to see if this
if this modified madsvox
model for monocots modified monocot
model
would uh would hold true um and
i want to use this slide to sort of
point out
two issues that are going to take us
through the talk and one is that
there are discordant patterns between
gene expression and organ morphology
across the monocots now
in some groups like zmas you still
largely had the abc model functioning
although the c-class genes there were
two of them and their function was
slightly divided between the statement
and carpal world
and in some tulips you did find this
expression of expansion of b-class genes
to that outer world
however in other tulips it seemed like
the b-class genes were missing entirely
and interestingly they had um petals
that
perhaps were actually all sepals instead
of two worlds their teeples might have
been
simple whirls instead of petal whirls
and so that got a little bit interesting
but we started to see across monocots
that many
um mono um in the b-class genes
this is all b-class genes here um
arabidopsis
has two and they interact as obligate
heterodimers in order to function
and then some monocots um like in this
agapanthus you also just have
one of each gene one one deaf and one
glow or one pistilotta and one ap3
and they do heterodimerize for function
however they're and they're expressed
all the way to the outer teeple so maybe
this is a modified monocot model
but in others you have three genes of
one and one of the other
and they can seem to function as
heterodimers or maybe function as
homodimers as well
so there wasn't really a um a
universal way to be able to understand
gene copy number
gene expression and the function of
these in
in creating organs um i just want to
zoom in quickly on the
um the one played
to make this more clear this is the
asparagus and
um you can see here again up close that
this also didn't correlate with
with the features of the whirls in that
the gray piocent has all petal-like
looking structures
everything's expressed everywhere but
asparagus also has
all petal-like looking structures and
the outer teeple world
has no b function in it at all so the
copy numbers and the expression patterns
are going to really be essential to
understand what's happening with these
organs
and also to think about you know what
makes an organ a steeple or a petal is
it a position
or is it what it looks like and
so that's what uh um i'll introduce the
ginger brailies in a second but that's
what i was sort of dealing with and
looking at
the some of the flowers that i was
looking at and that we had these
structures can you guys see my pointers
pointer if i use it is it going around
okay great thank you um and so we had
often called these structures here
um petaloid stamens or staminodes but
they were petaloid
and that's because they sort of look
like a petal in the classical term of a
petal of a lily or of an arabidopsis
however the petals of canna um don't
look like petals at all in fact they're
sort of sepaloid if you will and a
little bit longer
and so the question of whether or not
the petal genes
in quotes were on in the stamen worlds
um doesn't make sense because you
wouldn't expect these petal genes to be
owned in the stamen worlds and so which
petal jeans are you looking for
so it's really important to understand
that we call these
stamens because of their position they
look like petals because they look like
petals of other plants
and so maybe we need to talk about the
morphology about what makes them petals
petal-like looking um rather than
thinking about identity
as a as a as a construct or as a process
that we can unfold and if we
go beyond that um you can see that this
one-to-one correlation between the
position and the structure and
arabidopsis gives this false impression
that organ identity is a feature it's a
static feature of an organ
where in fact it's really an emergent
property of the underlying dynamic of
interactions
between right uh j regulatory networks
um and organ development
so this is a strelitzia this is canna
which i showed before
and this is acostas and i just want to
point out the stamens and strelitzia
are long and filamentous um the petals
look like
nothing that you would call a petal in
fact what they're trying to do is look
like stamens so it looks like they have
more pollen on them and that is
attractive to birds to come in
and that's what you're seeing up here
this is not pollen this is colored
petals
the pollen is actually tucked deep
inside
um and then you know and then the sepals
i don't know what they look like here
but
this idea that we need to think about
not exactly
organ identity but really what the
organs look like their organ morphology
and what genes might underlie or genetic
networks might underlie those
morphological characteristics
so um i'll now introduce the center
barrels and talk about them for a little
bit
um it this is a clade of monocots that
are
within the kamalinid monocots so that
makes them relatively close to things
like palms and grasses which we heard
about today um
from toby and that position
early on made them really helpful for
doing genomic analyses because i had
whole genomes from relatively closely
related lineages that we could use
to make homology assessments um
the ginger brailies uh without going
into too much detail
are loosely divided into two sets the
banana families and the ginger families
and what's important to know that note
here is that in the banana families
you have these stamens like i showed you
in stralizia which is here one of the
banana families
and these are long filamentous stamens
with the thicky located on top
and there's usually five or six of them
um there are monocots so they're in
worlds of three
and they have two worlds of stamens
giving them a potential for six
statements so an outer and inner world
and oftentimes one of the members of the
um of the inner world is aborted
so that there's only five statements
fertile statements
in the ginger lineage um this this
number of fertile stamens
has been significantly reduced to one
single fertile stamen or even a half
stamen in canna
and um and mara and then the marin tasty
the remaining stamens are petaloid or
laminar with conical epidermal cells
they're bright shiny
and they form the majority of the floral
display and so for example here's a
costas
and what you're looking at is all stamen
tissue there there's no petal that
you're looking at
the same here with canna these are all
the stamen tissue
that you're seeing and also here with
the marantesi
um and furthermore in the costasian
zinger bracey there's been fusion
of these staminoidal elements to form a
novel structure called the labella
and this is just some pretty pictures of
labelling to show you the bellow to show
you what what they look like
they really do dominate the floral
display and if you're a pollinator and
you're approaching one of these species
you're looking at the labellum for your
clues as far as your landing platforms
or the tubular structures that you'll
put your bill into
uh to grab the nectar um and that your
bill will
ultimately co-evolve with to become a
perfect form to be able to reach that
nectar
um and um speaking
um anthropogenically of organisms that
aren't human
um but so what this has um
started to allow us to think about is
how there is an evolution of fitness and
form because when you have something
like musa which has many stamen
um and they're covered with pollen that
pollen go everywhere so there's a lot of
pollen production
um when there's more fertile stamen when
you have these polaroid stamen there's a
reduction in
fertility for direction and pollen
production however there's this greater
participation in the floral display and
that has to do with getting the
pollinators into the right place
so when you're thinking about fitness of
these plants you can't just think about
oh how much pollen are they producing
you have to think about where is that
pollen going is it getting onto a
particular organism and how well is it
being delivered
to the stigma of the con specific so
that it can affect fertilization
so um thinking then about um
these processes underlying form and
function i've now taken the ginger
brailies and cut them out into looking
at the sepals the petals the stamens and
the carpals
and i just want to bring up three um
trends or processes that are going to be
important in this talk
um one is this idea that we've got this
reduction in fertile stamens but then
it's been replaced by this petaloid
structure so there's this
idea that there's this common thing in
the petal and the stamen world and i've
already shown you that that's not quite
true the stamens are doing something
different than the petals of their own
plant
but there was an early question as to
whether or not the petals were just been
moved over into the same
world so you've got this comparison
between filamentous stamen
and laminar or petaloid stamen
um you then also have this uh perianth
dimorphism where in some in
in musa you have two worlds of petal
like structures whereas in everybody
else you've got
different types of sepals and petals so
there's perianth dimorphism or separate
steeples and puddles so you've got two
different types of developmental
possibilities
between the sepals of musa versus the
sepals of the remainder of the order
and then finally there's fusion or and
sometimes
lack of separation between worlds and so
fusion happens
in the labellum of in the stamen worlds
of of
costas and um caustaceae and
cinderbracey and it happens between the
sepals and the petals
of musa although one petal is left free
and and is put off to the side of that
so i initially thought about this from a
very much an organ identity perspective
and worked with many of graduate
students
and postdocs and undergraduates in my
lab first at berkeley and then moving to
cornell
most of this work was done at berkeley
um
and um when i was at uc berkeley and
we looked at the matt's box genes
specifically the b class genes also the
c
and the e to try to get at um and that's
because in monocots they're the a-class
genes are not involved in floral
development
um and largely to get at what what might
be happening how many copies do we have
where are they expressed and so this is
just a show we looked at the copy
numbers
for most of them we had more copies than
you would have anticipated from
arabidopsis but
as many as you would have anticipated
from all the other monocots that had
been looked at
and then we looked at gene expression
and specifically using costus and musa
as our model
organisms to say okay does gene
expression happen as we might have
thought
do we have tuples in musa with common
b-class expression all the way out to
the outermost world
and then what's going on with these
petaloids
i'm sorry okay
um so uh when we did this comparative
gene expression what we found was that
um boy it's just all over the place
um it i always say this is like a bad
game of genga
you've got a lot of expression um and no
real patterns came through
and without going into any details i'm
going to say that just the out
the wow moment that came out of this is
that we realized that so in costas
these petaloid stamens had a particular
gene expression pattern
and we found the same expression pattern
in the petaloid stamens of canna
and in some of the petals of marantaceae
which are somewhat more petaloid
marantasa and low ac
so we started to think well maybe it's
not really about
the organ and where it is or the
identity but maybe it's about this
process of what the organ looks like
and that led us into thinking about
petaloidia as a process
so there's two things that make
something pedaloid one it's shape it's
laminar rather than being radial
um and that's shown over here with musa
being a radial filaments and
and canna being very laminar and then
there's also visual qualities involved
but today i'm just going to focus on the
shape or the laminar
and so research in the uh early 2010s
had um started to and and even
prior to that had started to understand
that um this laminar shape was the
result
of a polarity network
and that when you had a balanced
expression of ad axial
and ab axial expressed genes you would
get a margin
and at that margin you would have
outgrowth of um
of of a lamina so this laminar this
primordial primordial polarity network
looks like this you've got
fab fab and rev which are three genes
that are on the ad axial side again in
arabidopsis
and then you have the cannadies and the
yabbies which are on the abaxial side
and balanced expression of those genes
will give marginal expansion
so our hypothesis um and so this is the
way i've sort of
cartoonized that network and then our
hypothesis was that
um this polarity network
would be um used
in making this morphological
differentiation across the zinger really
so perhaps in musa
the network was broken the balance was
broken and that led to a radialized
filament
whereas in costas and canada you had
balanced expression giving you this
laminar structure
um also we could think about whether or
not the laminar stamen
was uh that we have in our early
diverging lineages of angiosperms
was in fact balanced as a as a laminar
structure and so
that's where the musa becoming broken
comes from so in fact castus and canna
would be the ancestral form and musa
independently broke
its um its uh
well moose sites just say the whole
banana group sorry broke that um
lineage um broke that balance
and um and we're still looking at that
question as to if this balance is broken
and the same in musa and low easy and
heliconia ac or whether or not
it's um evolved the ancestral form of
the zinger release was to have that
balance broken
so what and this is the work of anna
almeida who's a graduate student at the
time
and um brought up her name before and is
now a um
assistant professor at cal state
university east bay
and what she did as part of her phd work
was to
take the musa uh take a comparative
transcriptomics using
organ specific transcriptomes and she
took the
the um transcriptome from musa which is
regular
filament and costs this with its
petaloid filament
and she looked at the expression of
genes compared across those groups
and most genes were expressed one-to-one
between the two had a very similar
expression
however there was one gene that was
incredibly highly expressed in musa
but had a very low relatively right
along the line of expression and costis
and if you put that into a more of a
graphic form
you can see that this gene um sorry okay
moose is up here
so this uh gene is a yavy25 gene
is very highly expressed in the musa
filament it's very not
you know low expression in costas
filament it also has a high expression
in the brassica rapid filament
indicating that maybe this is the idea
that this boundary has been broken
and it's broken by a gabby 2-5 gene
in addition there's a kanati gene that
also has high expression in the filament
and farther studies led us to say that
okay yeah this is what seems to be
happening
in these filamentous structures you have
an
unbalanced polarity network caused by
the over-expression of one of these uh
genes um in this case they were the
kanadi and the gabby so they're on
what we think is the ab axial side
however in maize
uh it looks like these are flipped and
so it's it's not exactly
we're not still sure in the cinderellas
is whether it's adaxial or adaxial but
we do know that it's it's flipped
relative to that expression
um so this gets into saying that
uh rather than looking at this organ
identity which required an assumption
that identity itself was a process
we need to start thinking about all of
the different processes that underlie
the morphologies that we're interested
in
we then we move to laminarity which is a
process it's part of this polarity gene
network
and we can see that the process is is
that
you get the breaking of the network when
you get in just an unbalance of
expression
either on the ab axial or at axial side
um and so then the other process we
wanted to really start looking at was
fusion
because we know we have flu fusion in
the floral tube of
musa and also that's creating this
beautiful and charismatic labellum of
caustaceae and zindabaracy as this
effusion is as part of that and so this
is now the work of heather phillips
who's a second year graduate student in
the lab and heather has really taken on
fusion as her
with a tour de force to see if we can
start to unders using zender burleson
model system to start to understand
what's going on in fusion
and so what i'm going to do for the rest
of the talk is transition into other
processes that we've been looking at
first in the zinger barely's but also in
other systems and students that i have
working on different systems
um to get at how these processes are
underlying
organismal evolution in the lineages for
which they're
um in the lineages for which they confer
some kind of um adaptive and
evolutionary
scenario adaptive advantage or
evolutionary scenario
so um and heather just gave a
departmental seminar today
at noon um so during the lunch break if
you made it over to her departmental
seminar not physically but virtually
on here cornell and she talked about
this
in in even greater detail than i'm going
to tell you about today
but fusion is a really interesting
process in plants because
it is not a single thing we recognize
fusion um as the result of um
separate organs that come together to
form a single unit
often called syn organization that unit
then develops its own develo
evolutionary trajectory it functions as
a unit
um it is it often is a key innovation
uh that allows for diversification and
specialization of form
and it can happen through multiple
developmental trajectories
um so as heather says it's not just a
lack of separation
um and i won't go through those
developmental trajectories but i'm sure
many of you have dealt with them in your
work
um there is a um
we do know that in and at least um a
couple of model systems
this trajectory developmental trajectory
and maybe more than one
is mediated by these boundary genes or
the nam and kuke genes
and um these genes are are critical for
keeping
primordia separate if you don't have
expression of these genes
then the primordia don't separate
um whether or not they actively fuse is
what's in question and needs to be
studied on an individual
this is going to be like the abscission
zone i feel like with um
with toby's talk that it's going to be
different in every single situation but
we're going to try to find that common
thread um
and i did have to show a picture of
narcissus here of a daffodil because
this is one corona that we can all be
behind these days
and they're flowering right now here in
ithaca so um but that's an example of
fusion
and of a novel organ it is not a petal
or a stamen
something in between literally
physically in between
um so within the zinger
uh we have a couple types of fusion
going on within the banana lineage we
have the ad nation of sepals and petals
um and the stamens are typically unfused
within the ginger lineages we have the
fusion of these petaloid stamens to form
the labellum
there is also a single fertile stamen
that does not fuse so something has to
tell that organ
um to not join in with the crowd um and
this is the same with bananas somebody
has to tell that single
free petal not to join in with the with
the others
and then in all of them there's a fuse
trimeris carpel so fusion does happen
um in the um in the carpal
structure for for in the gymnasium of
all of these plants
so knowing what we now know of the nam
and cook three lineages heather looked
into
where these genes are produced and what
kind of mutants they form
and they've been characterized in
petunia
which has a nice fusion phenotype in its
flower as well as an arabidopsis
um and it's been shown that there are um
it's a little complicated but we
understand from what we understand
there's genes in gymnosperms and namcuc3
genes are in gymnosperms
however there's a gene duplication that
occurred at the base of the angiosperms
and some other further duplication that
might be specific to the brassicac
um but the data that heather has been
pulling up
um leads to suspect that it might be a
little bit larger than the brass of
casey or might be a little bit
more complicated than than we once
thought
so this is a tree that heather made
along with a postdoc in the lab jacob
landis and a rotation student david
wickel
and they pulled out contigs of the
naming q3 genes
from the 1kp dataset so a bunch of
transcriptomes
and those transcriptomes assembly as
well as context taken from mcbi
and they made this large tree you can't
read that so let me zoom in a little bit
closer and just to say that
there is heather found again that
there's this namm q3 like clay that is
in the
that is in the gymnosperm so it's sister
to the angiosperms and then there is
this duplication that occurred in the
angiosperms
um that duplication seemed to generate
separate
q3 as a q3 clade and then a separate nam
clade
right now this is the top of the tree
and now on the next slide i'm going to
go to the base of that tree
so now looking down the the q3 plate was
up here
here's the cube 1 and q2 plates that
were defined for arabidopsis and
arabidopsis is shown in in
with a star and you can see that there's
many other taxa that are
in this qq1 and q2 clade
um they are some are brassicaceae but
others are not
and many of them only have one copy so
they'll either have a
they'll have a q3 and then their name is
either
closely related to the arabidopsis cube
through two
or closely related to their arabidopsis
cube1 but they won't have that to copy
so it's it's unclear as to whether or
not there have been
um additional duplications that are j
and losses
and what we're seeing is the result of
that many of them had the
q1q2 duplication but then there's been
losses
or if there's some really interesting
selection going on that's causing these
two arabidopsis genes instead of falling
out together
falling out together to fall out in two
separate clades due to some
clade-specific selection that's
happening um
potentially due to different function of
those
clades so what we need to do is to look
at um
and heather's on this any specific
motifs which differentiate between the
cube1 and
q2 um and
identifying those motifs seeing how they
link with their function
during boundary formation um and then
looking at site-specific selection
regulatory regions and any expression
patterns that might give some clue as to
what the nan versus the q3 clades are
doing
and then within the nam what those
different clades might be doing
when organisms have more than one copy
um
and she's using transcriptome data from
the zinger baileys to identify
additional nam and q3 genes to start
with a model clade approach
and what you'll be doing is looking at
expression of
the namcute genes across the gingiva
rallies to see if they're involved in
the ad nation that you see
in the musa in musa using musa bastiou
as a
model organism or in the carnation that
you see in the stamens
using costa spicatus as a mono organism
and also it's important to note that
there's these
gene regulatory networks associated with
q2
cute i'm sorry with the cute genes keep
one 2 and 3
that involve some micrornas and also
that involve
pin and auxin accumulation
and how all of these relate to boundary
formation
is particularly interesting in that
there's also genes that are specific
to petals and genes that are specific to
stamens so there might be regulation
that is specific to where that
boundaries are forming it might
fusion might not be the same when it
happens but um
within the stem or the shoot of an
organism or when it happens
within the flowering component of of the
same
organism so that's going to be something
to look at so stay tuned for that
and also then still within the
cinderellas and thinking about things
like fusion thinking about color
coloration patterns thinking about
pollination we're looking at the
convergent evolution of these different
pollination syndromes um within cost
stacey
this is works being done in
collaboration with anna as well as
two postdocs in the lab and jacob landis
and in this case we have these wonderful
species pairs of a bee pollinated and a
bird pollinated taxon
and we're interested in seeing how these
species pair fall out
so that we can see if there's different
gene expression
different selection in genes that have
these closely related species
however they're able to be so different
in their pollination syndromes
and different in their floral form and
in their inflorescence form
um and we'll be looking at different
snips that might occur between b
versus bird pollination selection
differences that might occur on the
genes that seem to cluster with the bird
or
be pollinated plants and then also
expression differences in those
in those taxa um
so i'm going to skip two slides for the
interest of time
and move to um some work that we've been
doing now with calicordus and so this is
also in the monocots
you'll notice a trend there to stay
within the monocots um
although they'll blow that out of the
water too at the end and um
looking at again looking at the flowers
looking at floral syndromes and using
this as an i
as a way to get at the genes that are
underlying really
large phenotypic changes that occur
within this group
now within calicordus there's floor four
different floral syndromes
the mariposa lily the catsier star
tulips and fairy lanterns and if you
happen to be on the west coast right now
you're probably seeing some of these
they're flowering
um there's people out there collecting
them for us which is fantastic and
adriana will hopefully get out there
later this semester uh later this
season and you can see that they have
while the mariposa lily seems to be the
ancestral form
there's multiple evolution of these
different forms throughout the phylogeny
so you've got the cat's ear the star
tulip and the fairy lanterns evolving
multiple times
and we've already started to look at
some of these traits that are involved
in these so the nodding is something
very characteristic of the fairy lantern
and we're wondering how do you get from
something that's nodding to upright and
because again like in costas we have
these species pairs
of relatively closely related fairy
lanterns
with a cat's ear
in this case a mobilis with monopolists
we can start to tease apart the traits
that might allow these things to go from
nodding to being erect
and then from being very glaborous to
having
huge amounts of trichomes located here
on the petals the sepals don't have
trichomes however so we can also compare
sepals to petals
to get at this trichome difference and
that's one of the things we've been
using
um differential gene expression
to look at using organ specific and
taxon specific transcriptomics
but the story of calicorus that i want
to talk about in more detail today is
that of
graduate student ariana hernandez who is
a
fourth year graduate student and is
funded by an nsf
um uh graduate research fellowship
and um ariana is really interested in
polymorphism within species and this
becomes a really interesting thing for
breeding as well because we often talk
about traits as though they
they occur and there might be a little
bit of variation but there are some
traits that are just
really inherently polymorphic and
calicorna species seem to really have a
lot
have to seem to have a lot of these um
these are three species all the swedish
plumari
that are all polymorphic however none of
them are as polymorphic as the queen of
polymorphism
calichordas venustus so these are all
the same species
um in fact some of them can all occur
within the same population
and yet and we know that they're the
same species for a variety of reasons
but they've got this diversity of petal
color
of petal spot presence and of anther
colors
that makes them um a really interesting
uh characteristic
uh trait to study polymorphism to study
within this lineage
so adriana is looking at the genes that
are involved in color formation
wanting to know you know what genes are
involved using differential expression
analyses
is selecting acting on these genes at
the population level
and then what other traits are
associated with petal color and this
includes epidermal pattern
patterning of the spots to say that you
know a spot is more effective if it has
conical epidermal cells or if it has
flanned epidermis cells because then it
can it can function more effectively in
attracting
pollinators or other functions that it
might have so
looking at these other um even cellular
traits that are associated with petal
color
but in order to do this she really needs
to understand what's going on within the
populations of calachortis
so we have different phenotypes are they
differently
placed across the biogeography
so this is the distribution of
calicordus venustus and these circles
show
where these different phenotypes occur
and you can see in the southern
populations you have almost the full
suite of polymorphism
everything from white to deep red and in
some of this
populations along the sierra although
you'll have more white you can also see
the deep reds the purples the violets
occurring in these populations if you go
more coastal you get
more white populations and also as you
go north
and along so this is i'm sorry i should
say this is i'm just assuming everybody
knows this is california
um but this is california and this is
the central valley and it's ringed by
the
uh the coastal range and the sierra
nevada
um down here is where you have la down
here at the bottom right oh right in
here
um so los angeles is located here
and the the bay is right up here so
here's berkeley
um and so you know what is the gene flow
among these populations how can you
allow how can you maintain such
polymorphism and populations
given this gene flow and are there um
polymorphisms and selection under in
these populations that might underlie
the
the different coloration patterns that
are occurring
so adriana used a um rna-seq analysis
to obtain her data to from collections
from across that range in california
um callings filtering the samples
sequencing having the libraries
filtering the samples and calling snips
and then analyzing those to and for a
population structures and gene flow
across the structures
and um she had just under 200 000 snips
that she used to to do these analyses
and so what she found is that the
genetics clustering
really shows that there's geographic
cohesion rather than phenotypic
differentiation so all the red ones
aren't
the same thing in fact you have
populations that are very polymorphic
and those populations are clustering
together um
you've got this the purple population
down here in the south surrounding the
los angeles area and a little bit to the
north of that
and then you've got populations that go
up the sierra
and a different set of populations going
up the coastal range and those are these
here
this group of populations here is shown
in this uh
structure analysis uh here so this group
there's clearly some sort of
hybridization going on
with the the some of the purple
populations here so
this is all the gray i should say right
here
moving up the the coast range and so
you you can see clear population
differential but you can also see that
there is some gene flow and there is
some admixture going on in some of these
populations
this is an interesting group this is a
group that occurs um
only in kings canyon um here in the
sierra nevada in
um uh the giant redwoods area and so
that might you know might be some sort
of
um intellectual population there it's
going to be interesting to get at that
more closely
but also audrey noticed that there is a
pattern of isolation by distance
uh the largest genetic differentiation
between being between these northern
populations
and it seems like the populations came
from a more southern distribution
and then have moved up the coast range
and moved up the sierra
and gene flow is maintained along those
populations
so just in summary of that um we have
variation
and there the next step is to really
start to look at the ecological
associations and the function of that
variation
so are there pollination uh
reasons why you get mostly white flowers
in the north and the disparate
polymorphic populations in the south are
they pollinated by different pollinators
are they different temperatures um you
can imagine a red flower and being mean
a lot uh
dark darker flower having a lot more
heat than a lighter flower and does that
influence timing of flowering is an
influen
influenced pollinator preference um and
then also could this be for uv
protection adriana had noticed that
the um the darker color flowers tend to
be higher up in elevation
and that might be indicating that they
are having some anthocyanin production
as a response to uv
exposure to uv so using all of these
methods using the population genetics
using the differential expressions
analyses we can start to get at what are
the um
what are the genes underlying these
different traits and how they might be
functioning
at within these populations to uh to
generate different adaptive phenotypes
so looking at um i know i'm
running on time but i will go through
this so um
another student in the lab um jesus
martinez gomez so actually adriana is a
third year student now and he is a
fourth year student sorry i'm losing
track
um it's hard in isolation um
we uh jesus is looking at inflorescences
in
um as as branches and branching patterns
within
um within monocots and particularly
within the asparagus
so those of you who have studied in
fluorescence development knows
know about words like umbles and thirsts
and signs and
bostraces and double racines and
panicles
especially if you work on grasses you
know panicles and
um there's a the structure of the the
umble
is characterized in the umbilifery um
or the apac as as this humble structure
but allium
in the um asparagus has also been
characterized as having
an umbel and it looks very superficially
at least very similar to that in the
umbilicary
um however uh outside of the amarillo
desi
you have outside of the um allium you
have the amarillodacy and that influence
in fluorescence is characterized as a
bowstrix
a bostrix or a helicoid sign and in the
bottom of the slide i'm just going to
show you how that evolves
a bostrix is um is a sympodial branching
or a sine where you get the termination
of a branch and then the next branch
terminates the next branch terminates
and so on
um it has thought that the allium umble
evolved from that type of sign
um and that it did so through different
types of branch rearrangements and then
differential branch elongation
and so here i show a racine which again
is a monopodial structure so you've got
a single
axis and then all of the flowers are
coming off of that axis
versus the syme which is a sympodial
structure
many podia making up that structure
so in a racine you could also imagine
evolving an umble from a racine where
you just had a lack of internal
elongation and developmentally that
actually might be simpler
however because it was um because the
allium is
clustered within this larger um sorry
the larger amarillo daisy
it was thought that it was likely
evolved from that syme structure
so asus has been testing this looking at
different continuous time markov models
to see whether or not
it is more likely in a phylogenetic
context
that the umble of allium is derived from
a racine
or derived from a sine
this is the phylogeny that he has of all
of the asparagalese
you can see it includes the
amaryllidaceae here includes the
asparagus
and um and here is the um and the
orchidaceae are included as well and
iridaceae
and in the amarillodacy that's where you
would be getting the the umbel
of the of the allium and you can see all
of these are coded as being that humble
structure
that you see in the amarillo daisy um
i should say he's been doing this work
with two undergraduate assistants
uh jason and aaliyah and they've been
coding all of these uh morphologies from
the literature
and he has shown using his models in
this phylogeny that in fact the ancestor
of the amarillo desi
amble is a racine so this humble did
derive
from a racine-like structure rather than
being sign derived
so jesus's next steps are to look at
this humble evolution in the context of
models
um uh present
i'm not gonna say because i'm gonna say
fast um there's some models of different
uh morphological evolution where you can
see
how branching structures evolve through
time and using
leafy as a gene as a candidate gene you
can evolve all these different
structures
however przenskowitz's models did not
have an
umble in them and so he's just been
adding
elements using terminal flowering one
tfl one and leafy to try to get the
structures that he needs to be to derive
an humble
and then using tissue culture using
transformation to see if he can take the
humble of garlic
and either down regulate or upregulate
leafy to see if you can re-evolve
or you know redevelop this racine or
this sign that you see
in an ancestral condition
okay and i'm really running out of time
now and so i'm going to go through these
um
relatively quickly and i know it's going
to cut into my my
my talk time but i have the the whole
slide view so i can't see
taylor and so i can't see her yelling at
me so i'm sorry about that
but um so uh clarice is
uh working in clarisse is a second year
student in the lab
and they're working on phyllotaxis so
looking at the arrangement of organs on
the plant shoot
and clarisse has come on to a really
interesting system where many plants
that we
talk about are disticus or alternate in
their arrangement
or decostate and opposite in their
arrangement
or they're following a fibonacci spiral
which is that spiral phyllotaxy that you
see in many of the plant systems that we
look at
however in the genus costas or actually
in the holocaust stacey
you have a a philotoxic pattern that is
spiromenisticus
and it's shown up here if you know about
phyllotactic bran
ratios it's a 1 7 branching pattern with
a really interesting philotactic ratio
that has only a degree of divergence
angle of 47 degrees
which is very different from the 137
that you would expect from a fibonacci
series
and so clarisse is interested in seeing
understanding how this spiral meniscus
is generated
are there anatomical trends that are
associated with this what happens to the
vasculature
when you when you have a primordia being
generated
so close to one another during the
spiraling
pattern and what does natural variation
what can it tell us about the evolution
and the ecological associations of these
traits
so clarisse has been measuring even in
isolation
changes that occur between the the
vegetative part of the
of the um the plant and the reproductive
part of the plant
and how those changes might reflect on
the ecological
um nature this part of the plant doing
photosynthesis
the reproductive part of the plant being
involved in reproduction on
in pollination and needing to acts have
access to pollinators
and then clarisse has been taking
different developmental time points to
find that shift
between the reproductive the vegetative
and the reproductive
um aspect of spiral meniscus phyllotaxy
and we'll be looking at auxin trans
auxin transport and gene expression
of for example in all the pin homologs
to see
if um how those are responding
to auxin maxima when you have a
phyllotactic pattern that is so
close to being um where the phyllotactic
angle is so close
you don't have that distance that we
think about with typical spiral
phyllotoxy
that gives us the the auxin sink and
then
uh the next the next um organ is
produced in that sink
and this can be really important because
when you think we are bound
in the the crops that we work with we're
really bound by what they do
um for their um by their fellow taxi
their pollination is bound by that their
vegetative growth
whether or not they can put their leaves
out and get maximum photosynthesis
is bound by phyllotaxis and we kind of
think of phyllo taxi as being something
inherent
and not modifiable but the research that
clarisse is doing might be able to get
at
how it's possible to modify phyllotaxy
to the benefit of a plant um and
and uh traits that the plant might uh
additional traits that the plant might
have that that changing the phyllo taxi
and modifying phyllo taxi might be able
to benefit
and so using the natural diversity of
phyllo taxi using that within a
phylogenetic context
uh clarisse has been working to to get
at that
um and then finally i want to talk a
little bit about the work of
carrie tribble who's a graduate student
who's just finishing up um and she is at
uc berkeley
and she's been looking at underground
storage organs
and how these underground storage organs
have been
are critical in supporting plant growth
and development
now many uh many monocot
taxa are geophytes meaning that they do
have underground storage organs
and kerry's work is really focused on
characterizing the geophytic structures
from a bunch of different
plants but in particular she's been
looking at this lineage bomaria
which is in the austromeriac it's a new
world taxon
and you can see here in red where this
organism has underground storage
structures so it is a geophyte
it has uh storage structures it uses its
rhizome in some taxa
in other taxa it uses these root tubers
and the root tubers are located on the
tip of the roots in some tanks it uses
both a rhizome and a root tuber so it's
it's really
kind of doubling up on the system and so
for many
if you look at herbarium collections
they often don't include this
underground morphology and so kerry has
had to travel throughout
south america and dig up a lot of plants
and uh
to characterize these root morphologies
so she's looking now at the functional
genetics of these morphological
innovations really trying to get at
um the the transcriptomes of the fibrous
roots
versus the tuberous root to see what
genes are involved in making the
the tuberous root and then also
comparing that to
other organisms that have uh underground
storage organs
to see if there is some deep homology um
in the
in the formation of these underground
storage organs
um her studies have shown that there is
um
these are pca analysis and you can see
that they do cluster by tissue types
so these are roots uh these are rhizomes
and these are above ground
vertical shoots however you don't see
clustering by the type of
fibrous root versus tuberous root in in
this particular analysis
but looking at the functional genetics
of morphological innovations across
other um other starch-producing
organisms are
two root tuber organisms she found 271
genes that were overexpressed in the
tuberous roots
in comparison to the fibrous roots in
bomeria
many of them were involved in cell wall
modification flowering time starch
biosynthesis which you would expect
and many of them have also shared with
things like potato
and onion even though potato is a
different type of tuber
it's a stem tuber an onion is a
different type of thing altogether
it's a it's a bulb which is a leaf
morphology
so there seems to be something involved
in making these underground
storage organs and she's also looking at
some of taking
the next level on some of those genes
such as the pebp genes
which include terminal flower one
flowering locus tea and mother of
flowering locust tea
and showing that bomaria has these genes
they're differentially expressed in
tuberous roots versus
fibrous roots and that they also
are shown here in red these are also
genes that have been shown to be
differentially expressed in potato
and in allium and again that's really
interesting given that those are
different organs one is again one is a
bulb and
one is a stem tube or not a root tuber
okay um so with that i'm out of time and
i
and i do have to apologize to shayla
because i'm not going to get to talk
about cycads and how cool they are
um but i do want to say that we're also
looking at really neat things such as
thermogenesis in cycads and volatile
production in cycads
and how that volati volatile production
has co-evolved with the weevils um that
that um and with the weevils and looking
at the genetics underlying volatile
production and how that has evolved
across time as well
so i can only i'm sorry
now i'm let me see if i can get back to
the
i seem to have lost everybody on my
this is not uh that is okay i can uh
facilitate questions if there's any in
the chat we have time for one question
can you still still see my screen i
don't know why i can't
yes and we have a question from jeff
doyle
jeff did you want to go ahead and ask
your question sure
hey chelsea nice talk if we want to
understand homologies of current floral
structures should we take as a starting
point the most recent common ancestor
rather than relying on our preconceived
notion of what a petal or a stamen
actually is which at the minimum is
implicitly biased by a eu dicot centric
view of morphology and development
it seems like anything prior to the
common ancestor is in some sense
irrelevant
have you done any ancestral
reconstructions for your zinja burally's
flowers
so specifically for the petals and yeah
right
yeah i mean i think that um it you know
it's going to depend on how far you go
out to the out groups because once you
start to move to the out groups you
start to worry you start to
be less able to make homology statements
across these different groups so um
i think that that in in in essence is
the entire
is the entire problem because you're
trying to make homology statements
about identity and really organ identity
isn't what
isn't something that you can make deep
ovology statements about because it's
it's an emergent property of that
particular organism
so you think about like orchids there's
not a pedaled identity of an orchid
because there's two different types of
petals
and their ancestor their ancestrally we
don't know exactly where that evolved
orchids have it their out group doesn't
their sister lineage doesn't have the
two different petal types
but what becomes almost more essential
to think about is
what is causing that um
what is causing the difference in in
what you see in that lineage or what's
what's
what's relevant within that lineage and
and i guess that's the point i was
trying to make at the beginning is that
we really if we started not thinking
about identity but starting thinking
about the process from the beginning
that's that's where you need to focus
does that does that get at that so
thinking about okay well
where does if you think about fusion is
the process
what's happening in the ancestor or you
think about petaloidy as the process and
laminarity and polarity
then you can say okay did the ancestor
have this or not and then how is it
involved within this
evolved within this lineage and i think
that even within lineages we're finding
that there's different ways
that they can use the same genetic
structure the same genetic pathway
to affect um
quite similar phenotypes
i don't know if that got it or not but
it was a really good question a very
good point and i hope a point that i
kind of
made throughout the talk
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu